If, all of a sudden, we see JP Morgan and all these different big financial companies...
...say, you know what, we're just moving everybody to Berlin.
Now, there's a tangible impact on jobs...
...and that's gonna influence the conversation.
And it's the same in the United States once we see that...
...we're talking about this nationalism, Trump versus Senator Clinton...
...or Secretary of State Clinton.
If all these businesses are reacting to...
...this "Take Back Our Country" movement by leaving.
That sets the tone for the election as well.
Look, if it happened that all these companies said we're out,...
...why would it be any different here?
But, on the flip side, if the United States is open...
...and we adhere to our treaties then, all of a sudden,...
...tech companies, in particular in the UK, who want to be able to work...
...with the European Union and have the treaties already in place,...
...they might come here.